hey 42 here Paterno phobia is the fear
of being tickled by feathers welcome to
RIT it cost seven million dollars to
build the Titanic and two hundred
million dollars to make a film about it
there is enough water in Lake Superior
to cover all of North and South America
in one foot of liquid when Star Wars and
New Hope hit theaters in 1977 France was
still executing people using the
guillotine owls don't have eyeballs
they have eye tubes when hippos are
upset or angry their sweat turns red
camel's milk doesn't curdle nowhere in
the Humpty Dumpty nursery rhyme does it
say that Humpty Dumpty is actually an
egg most streets in Japan don't have
names they instead use an addressing
system where they divide areas into
blocks and give those blocks numbers the
only two animals that can see behind
themselves without turning their heads
are the rabbit and the parrot elephants
have a specific alarm call that means
human it sounds like a deep rumble
horses use facial expressions and move
their ears to communicate with one
another every possible starting position
of a standard Rubik's Cube can be solved
in 20 moves or less there is only one
country between North Korea and Norway
Russia New York City is farther south
than Rome and finally Oxford University
is older than the Aztec empire by over
300 years thanks for the view subscribe
for more 42
you